hi guys welcome back to the 38th ever
episode of the ice coffee hour
i'm shelby church your guest today and
we've made
thirty five thousand five hundred and
fifteen dollars and one cent
wow that was amazing thank you that was
great what are you guys gonna do when
you hit a hundred thousand
some sort of celebration oh you know
what
jack's gonna get a rolex no that's not
true yes yes yes we've been
trying to convince jack to get the rolex
doesn't it don't do that don't say that
yeah that's exactly no
that's exactly right no don't say that i
support that
thank you yeah i think that's a great
investment a tesla
i think the rolex is going to be better
for you yeah i don't know graham is so
fixated on me getting a rolex i think
it's a bad idea
you think shelby i don't know much about
rolexes in general so i'm like how much
even are they
yes a lot what twenty thousand oh less
gosh no less less five thousand more
eight yeah about that give or take
but it's going to keep its value so
that's why i tell jack get a rolex
hold its value you can always sell it oh
oh and to sweeten the offer i
i said if jack needs his money at any
point i'll buy it at the same price he
paid for it
oh wow so i can never lose it so i guess
you might as well
you could but i'm tying up so much money
that's the issue yeah do people watch
videos on that kind of thing
okay yeah we actually the podcast we
filmed before this
we had federico talks watches and he's
a watch dealer and he talks about
high-end watches and like which watches
go up in value and which go down in
value and like what are good deals
rolex submariner was a good choice for
jack there's a channel for everything
now
yeah every random thing that's cool
though yeah do you watch any weird
channels like that i wouldn't call it
weird actually i'm
watching it yeah ahead let me like look
through myself i feel like we should
also
do shelby a little bit of justice and
introduce her a little bit more if you
guys have not seen
we've had her on the podcast before
she's a recurring guest
and it's exciting to have her here she's
a youtuber and now she's like building a
house in palm springs or something yeah
that's what i've seen on your instagram
yeah yeah i've liked your home videos
lately thanks
yeah they've been really interesting
yeah i have a bunch more planned
once i go back okay but yeah it's been
wild because there was a lot of things
we did not expect
getting the house but now it's getting
to a point where it's fun to see things
kind of start to come together
so walk us through this well actually
okay what are the weird youtube channels
you subscribe to
and then we'll talk about this i've
actually started now watching more of
the like stock
youtube channels which isn't like weird
different for me like people that talk
about stocks and
like zip traders and stuff yeah i've
watched why am i thinking like stalker
oh wait move jocker story stock or like
i'm thinking like stock like a stock
image yeah yeah yeah
no they're easy to put on like while
you're getting ready and just
listen to it so who do you listen to
specifically um
well i watch yours if you've made one on
it recently cause i'm like okay i trust
this info
um meet kevin i'll watch it yeah he
comes up
every podcast so we can't get rid of
that guy this is the running joke now
the inside joke is that every single
episode
his name is mentioned in some capacity
and one way or another somebody mentions
me well he uploads a lot so i'm like he
does
usually something if you go on youtube
there's like something there
yeah so i listened to his uh ev uh
crash video earlier today which i
thought was really good
really well research and it blows my
mind he'll make a stimulus video get 300
000 views
make this really intricate stock market
video that will help you make money
and it's like 90 000 views like it's
only a third of the people watch that
one even though that will help them make
10 times more money than a stimulus but
yeah i never watched the stimulus ones
i'm actually shocked that okay
does well i watch this i'm so shocked it
does well too
yeah i can't stand that those videos i
don't know what's going on with it i'm
like
it just i feel like you spend so much
time watching stimulus check videos
it's like it doesn't even pay out like
if you get like a thousand dollars from
a stimulus but you spent like a thousand
hours watching st
you know what i mean someone should have
you know early wage for that's not
looking good
speaking of which the uh what's his name
in the comments who always breaks down
how much the podcast makes
he should mateo mateo mateo okay how
about you
have him on yeah that one that would
bite my that would be interesting
that'd be cool to have him introduced
like here's how much the podcast has
made
this breaks down to be but but no my
idea was mateo if you add up
how many videos kevin has done and the
average length of those videos
with the average minimum wage see how
much
people would have made had they just
worked a job that would be smart yeah or
work for some sort of size
minimum wage that would be something it
would be yeah but if it's more
if they could have put that into
something else made like four grand
interesting i just don't know how you
like
couldn't you sum it up in a sentence
like what's going on with it or a couple
sentences it seems like you would be
able to right
i don't know it's not coming yet make a
video every day
not yet a lot of the i feel like
investing channels
sometimes i'm like these video this
video is dragging on
what so i can put another ad in and i
get it no i agree it
yeah no uh the reason why did you watch
the show the bachelor the bachelorette
yeah okay
what if i just told you that hey jason
marries sarah that's it
oh yeah where's the fun in that yeah
it's not versus you watch
all the episodes from star trek that's
the drama
what did nancy pelosi say today what did
steve mnuchin
come and like attack on twitter what did
what did
so-and-so say that's what you want to
know that's why people tune in it's like
every day it's like
what happened it's a reality show it's
it
should be it really should record it
shoot it like the kardashians
[Laughter]
i would watch that too yeah start to
finish but okay so anyway
let's go back to the the house
congratulations on the house
we were talking about it before on the
podcast yeah you were considering it it
was like the beginning of this whole
story
yeah we had looked at some houses but
didn't really didn't find anything yet
because
once the illness
the housing market in palm springs went
crazy
and we were looking even before that
because we were like these are really
good vacation rentals
people always rent them out old people
fly down
rent them for like a month you know um
so then we're like oh is this even worth
it like they're like a hundred thousand
dollars more than
we were wanting to pay but then we found
one that
the sellers didn't want to put it on the
market and so
there wasn't as much competition buying
it but there were issues with it
but if they had put it on the market it
probably would have gone over asking
like full cash offer and all that
because that's what was happening there
so how much did you buy it for but first
a word from our sponsor fundrise
in 2021 a truly diversified portfolio
needs more than just the traditional mix
of stocks
bonds and mutual funds it needs private
real estate studies have shown that
portfolios with an allocation to private
real estate
generally delivered a better risk
adjusted return with more
annual income and lower volatility over
the past two decades with fundrise this
level of powerful diversification is now
available to you fundrise provides
access to diversified portfolios of
private real estate to all investors
with their industry-leading easy to use
platform whether you're looking to add
stable cash flow via dividends or prefer
long-term growth through appreciation
fundrise makes investing in private real
estate as easy as investing in stocks
bonds or mutual funds fundraise's team
of real estate professionals carefully
vets and actively manages
all of their real estate projects and
with their easy to use website you can
track your portfolio's performance and
watch as properties across the country
are acquired improved and
operated via dynamic asset updates see
for yourself how 130 000 investors have
built a better portfolio with private
real
estate and it only takes a few minutes
to get started go to fundrise.com
iced coffee today that's
fundrisefundrisc.com
iced coffee fundrise.com iced coffee
thanks so much fundraise and back to the
podcast
we bought it for 752 000.
it's three bedroom two bathroom and it's
a classic mid-century house so they hold
their value better than the other random
new builds in the area yep um
and it's just cool like the whole
neighborhood has those style of houses
and the street it's on is really nice so
we liked that about it
but it was hard because like a few
months before we saw one that was like
perfect turn key for airbnb
but i forget what happened i think they
decided to not sell it
um okay and it was 25 000 cheaper got it
yeah
how did you work out the finances
between you and you and monica you just
each went 50 50 on this how do they
structure the loan were both of you on
the loan
yeah okay how much money are you putting
into this
well okay i was actually looking at it
today because i was like i feel like
this would be a good podcast but it's
definitely more than i thought like it's
always more
i knew it was gonna be okay new kitchen
different stuff in the backyard i didn't
know it was gonna be like the sewers
totally
messed up okay stuff like that the
electrical like
things just were not working at all um
so i'm going to guess
you got to be like 150 to do those
things
to do what you want to do maybe a little
less but
i think so far we put like 50 into it
and i think it will need another 50 at
least 100 okay
yeah if you had known it had all those
issues when you were gonna buy it would
you still have bought it no
oh my god i made a vlog to where i was
like okay what if we just cut our losses
and sold it and i was like that's
ridiculous like no do you think that
once it gets appraised it's going to be
appraised at a higher value than like
whatever you put into it
yes it will yeah yeah because what we
bought it for actually
i don't regret it because we did get it
for a good price it would have gone for
a lot more if it was on the market
because the ones that are fixed up the
ones with like a hundred thousand
dollars of work
in them are selling for like 9 30. so
i didn't know it was so expensive in
palm springs yeah well it wasn't like a
year ago
isn't it like just like the desert yeah
but people will
spend like three to five hundred a night
on airbnb
so you can make money is it the airbnb
that drove up the prices
no i would say it's a good community
and it's it's a big retirement community
so i'll tell you a lot of people in palm
springs that's your second or third
place
that's true i don't know why but people
are like
when i retire i want to own a home in
palm springs
but it's a community like think of it
like a big retirement community like
people go to las vegas is like the
gambling place
people go to palm springs like the
retirement place in in california they
seriously do
and they're the ones buying these
million dollar places that are
empty nine months out of the year and
they create this community of just
i don't say of old people but it's just
it's this community where you know
it's like you're surrounded by
like-minded
like aged people who like to golf
and who like to go to brunch and that's
what the community's been and it's it's
nice it's a nice community
i like it yeah it's nice to go for a
weekend
because you can rent a house if you
don't have a house there
and split it with friends for a good
price and have like a pool and
everything
so rather than staying at a hotel i feel
like that's kind of the appeal for
people in la
so and airbnb rates are crazy especially
when you start getting into
like the coachella whenever that comes
back coachella rates they're like you
can choose like three thousand
thousand dollars a night yeah so it's
crazy though because palm springs isn't
even that close
it's like still almost an hour drive but
you can still charge a lot because
there's not
that much in indio so
i fully intend to take advantage of that
why did you pick
palm springs too yeah it does seem
random right but
um my parents friends had a house there
and so we would go visit because
of course they're not actually added
that much um
so my family would go visit all the time
and once we started looking at places
we're like
oh this could be kind of cool as a
vacation rental and i was like looking
at how much
they were versus what you could rent
them out for it's like
okay maybe we could do this because i
would look at
condos and stuff in la and i just did
not really like any of them
like i thought about that for a second i
toured some even
but they would always be like i don't
know
not bright enough you know what i mean i
just wouldn't want to buy something and
commit to that
they're terrible investments yeah condos
and la are like the worst things that
you could buy
they lose money hoa prices are high
property taxes are high doing any
renovation in the condos
sucks not worth it you're better off
renting a condo yeah
and my friend had an ordeal she bought a
condo and then her neighbors were
horrible so i was like i don't yeah uh
was it tara tara tara oh but no but she
made so much money off of that bad
neighbor
after i met her i saw her videos on that
because i'm so i was so curious she was
telling me about this neighbor and like
okay
go to her youtube channel i watched the
video she's got like this crazy neighbor
that she films like she films a neighbor
like uh you know like
like how uh jack dougherty is like just
kind of messing with it
with his neighbor yeah she's filming the
neighbor just going off at her but the
neighbor's crazy
she's actually really creepy right yeah
she would get really mad that she would
have string lights up
but so her condo it's almost like sunken
down
and then the house is up above and she
just
was not okay with these lights thought
they were way too bright but they're
just normal string lights like just
i don't know go in a different room like
it was crazy she's made money off this
neighbor though
she's made tens of thousands of dollars
oh that's good yeah i know
so you could have a craziness why didn't
you just move into like tara's place and
then just taunt the neighbor
like build a whole career creepy i've
been over there and seen that lady i'm
like i would not sleep at night
why what would she do she is she like
invasive i don't know if
tara's put this she'd probably put it in
a vlog but she has tried to like get in
like she has footage on not a ring
camera but those security cameras of her
like
banging on the door and i just i
wouldn't want to deal with it but that's
content
like if you moved in the place you're
like i'm just going to get content
i don't know about that that would be
kind of scary
i know maybe if i had a roommate i
wouldn't want to be like alone at night
with this
lady knocking on me you know what this
is a perfect segue
for our sponsor today simply saved i'm
kidding that would be a perfect i might
be on this video to schedule them in
really yeah simply safe okay if there's
a sponsor here
thank you simply safe and uh we'll be
right back with this important message
so you you had the property in mind like
as
a a rental property or yeah like as an
investment
yeah so when are you gonna when are you
gonna rent it
it's just airbnb yeah on airbnb and then
possibly do some that are like a month
or longer because
sometimes in the winter people will want
to go for like a month yeah
so that's kind of easier to handle and
in palm springs you can only rent it
36 times per year but then you can do a
minimum
of the number of nights so you can only
do 36 rental contracts
but you could require a week minimum
or you could do one contract as a full
month that's so
weird yeah only 36 contracts so you
could hypothetically have one tenant
every day just for 36 days and then have
used up
yeah that's why like no one does that
they're
like it's really hard to book one night
in palm springs
how do they know they're pretty strict
on it i've heard really
yeah like the the neighbors will like if
they see a bunch of cars or they know
i guess it would be really hard for them
to know how many contracts you've done i
don't know how they would find that out
but they're really strict on like if
you're playing music outside you could
get a strike
because okay guys yeah
but my neighbors are awesome so they
don't seem like they would
do that if you could have bought
anywhere else would you have
like would you have to pick to buy
somewhere else or
are you happy with palm springs um i'm
pretty happy with it because i think
it'll be fun to go
there occasionally and it'd be like a
free place
to stay and i think it'll make money too
like i think it actually will and then
later on i don't know because i just
didn't want to buy here because it was
like
what can you get for even like a million
dollars that's true yeah
west adams view park for a million bucks
but then again i don't know i i i really
i really believe buying out of state now
i really believe whatever i do
whatever whatever i'm doing in the
moment like i believe in that
but i don't know that is good to have
belief that whatever i don't it's the
right thing but
i'll go on zillow and look at like texas
and stuff and i'm like wow isn't it nice
i love doing that yeah just seeing what
you can buy for like a hundred grand
somewhere else it's crazy
like yeah i've never even been to texas
but now i'm like i could have a pool
and stuff yeah one of my favorite things
to do is
uh just go on zillow and type in
like over 10 000 square feet with like a
million dollar maximum
and you just see some of the craziest
spots throughout the united states that
you could be like
there's parts of georgia we can get
these 15 000 square foot
mansions for like 750 grand it's insane
i just clicked through the pictures yeah
would you ever actually like consider
buying one of those places i don't know
maybe because i feel like it's like a
drop in the bucket at some point right
just to have like a place in georgia
fifteen thousand
percent issues yeah that's true so much
i'm like oh my god i'm glad it's
only a three bedroom house yeah i'm like
i just wouldn't want to deal with
painting the ceiling anywhere else it's
just that is true that's a good point
how much longer are you do you think
you're gonna have to work on this house
like two months i hope the yard's
already looking better
the kitchen just needs help the bedrooms
are fine
like we'll just they just need furniture
and we've already gotten like
a new electrical panel and like fixed
the sewer line and everything so like a
lot of the annoying stuff is
okay now you're doing a lot of the work
yourself
no we just painted the ceilings
ourselves because it was like the
holidays
so no one was really available and my
parents were in town and my dad's super
into that stuff so
we'll do it okay and honestly would not
recommend
painting a ceiling is not fun
like sanding it and everything painting
was horrible
i painted the outside of my duplex like
five years ago and it was one of the
most
horrible experiences and i thought too
like it was stucco
and i had five friends together and i'm
like we could do this in
two days one day is prep work one day is
paint
done that thing took like seven days
straight of like 15 hour days between
multiple people
and by the end of it i was so just over
it and exhausted i had a terrible
sunburn
my hands were just like all red and
cracky
from like just holding a paintbrush for
so long and aches and
it's horrible and i had paint that just
wouldn't come off my hands for like
weeks afterwards but uh yeah but i did
it i
saved like three grand but uh looking i
would have never done that again
yeah that's what i figured by the end i
was like this took us so long
i probably just could have been making
videos yep
and then professionals could probably
get it done way faster
because they have all the equipment yeah
they could do that they have all this
stuff ready just to spray it down
one spray like three coats they're good
to go so in the future
i do think it's a better idea focus on
videos and just i think so
get a professional to do it it was like
the excitement of just getting the house
like i think we just wanted to do
something to it
yeah and i'm like no way i'm over it
yeah i'm over doing any work myself
yeah put up this light though this was
uh my my crown
jewel achievement is putting up this
line yes
are you gonna consider getting uh more
properties
yeah i mean if this one does well if
it's not i mean i'm interested to see
how the airbnb
part of it goes we'll probably do like a
property manager
sort of thing that's what a lot of
people do there um but
if that ends up working out well then
i'm like
oh like tahoe big bear like that lake
tahoe would be
awesome wouldn't it be cool that's where
i thought about buying originally
before las vegas yeah though yes i've
heard they don't want any more rentals
they're good on that who knows though
yeah
lake tahoe is beautiful um i felt it
would be a little bit too
isolated difficult to get to because
either you got to take a flight to reno
and then drive an hour down to lake
tahoe
or it's like a seven hour drive yeah
it's a little bit more
remote but it's gorgeous like it is
those best months of the summer and the
winter
it is one of the coolest places yeah
it's cool how it's like winter earth or
summer there's stuff to do
and you could buy on the nevada side yes
that was the plan
yeah yeah weird that side is more
expensive everyone is paying a few
hundred thousand more
just for for tax reasons yeah and it
blows my mind it's like on one side of
the street
it'll be a million the other side of the
street won three
just for just for being in that
different state but how much do you
intend to make from
the palm springs place if you rent it
out like have you run the numbers and
but first a quick word from our sponsor
ladder life insurance life is full of
reminders of its beauty
whether it be making lots of money on
dogecoin eating a tasty snack or getting
a top performing video on youtube
these experiences are great reminders of
how beautiful life is and why it should
be protected
on that note it makes sense why people
get life insurance especially long-term
coverage which is surprisingly
affordable
why not pay a little bit each month to
protect the ones that you love if you're
asking yourself this
choose a ladder ladder makes it
impressively fast and easy to get
covered you just need a few minutes
and a phone or a laptop to apply ladder
smart algorithms work in real time so
you find out instantly if you're
approved and what's great is that there
are no hidden fees and that you can
cancel at any time
and since life insurance costs more as
you age now is the perfect time to cross
it off your list
go to ladderlife.com iced coffee that's
dot com ladderladderlife.com iced coffee
ladderlife.com
iced coffee thank you so much and back
to the podcast
i have i think it'll make like 50 to 60
000 per year i think it should make that
if not more
if we're like optimizing it but i'd
imagine we want to go there sometimes
and
i don't know when festivals will be back
all that kind of thing
and then after 20 ish to a property
management company that's like
40 to 50 and then the mortgage
is 30 000 a year including like property
taxes and all that
so then it that would be like 12 000 in
equity and then it would leave like
12-ish thousand unless we like end up
making more but i feel like that
should be doable got it so you're gonna
make you
probably about a thousand a month from
this and how much
cash did you put in um we
put 250 down between the both of you
yeah
so 125 12 000
so you're gonna make about a nine
percent return on your money
between equity and cash flow and you're
going to get some pretty good write-offs
from that too
that's what i was thinking too i was
like all these renovations i'm pretty
sure with airbnb even like the furniture
and stuff
yes but we'll check on that yeah you can
depreciate a lot of this stuff
yeah you can appreciate the house you
can make a ton of videos about it
right yeah um and oh yeah you're right i
think the videos is really
where there's probably more money making
videos
honestly on the house like so what if
you make 12 grand you'll make
30 000 talking about making the 12. yeah
i mean i already have some brand deals
lined up with it that i'm like i would
not have gotten
is it like house brand deals yeah it's
like renovating the kitchen
basically we're doing a video on
monica's channel it's with fiverr
where someone on fiverr is like
designing the kitchen
that's right they reached out to me i
couldn't figure out an integration with
fiverr like i just couldn't think of
anything that's
that's smart yeah i've worked with them
before and it's fun because i'm just
like
have them do something that i tested out
is the whole
oh you know what i think i've seen one
of your videos in fiverr you create the
whole
video around fiverr oh yeah i let them
like write a script
okay and yeah and i i actually
i i had more sellers i didn't put in the
video but they came up with a bunch of
ideas and i was like these are good like
i'm
saving these for later really like what
ideas i don't remember now i'd have to
go
like yeah wow that's not bad that's
pretty smart i wanted to do that fiverr
thing i thought it would be fun
to go into fiverr and find like some
like personal finance guru or someone
yeah
that would be willing to give advice and
then get graham to get advice from them
in like a fiverr video yeah yeah what
happened to that
because the title was you vetoed it dude
you bought a wig
so you could like disguise yourself you
bought like he bought facial hair and
stuff because you're going to disguise
him and like
bring up different like financial
scenarios for him to be in and then
would it be like a zoom call with them
they'd be like i don't i think something
like that like
i paid fiverr for financial advice yeah
yeah something like
that i mean that stuff does well people
do like
i paid a fiver seller to edit my video
like those do super well yeah that's
what i said i thought it would be funny
it would be funny i think when i'm out
of video ideas we'll do that
yeah that'll be like the backup like uh
jack it's time
it's time we do that fiverr video shelby
when are you gonna do another
what i spend in a week i'll probably do
one with about the house like would i
spend in a week
renovating a house no uh as a homeowner
oh as a homeowner and palm springs
almost six twenty six okay so say 25
what i spend in a week is a 25 year old
homeowner yeah
that's your video right there yeah that
those videos do well
huh yeah they're annoying to make but
they make me feel bad about one of the
best those are the best kinds of videos
we're telling everybody to do those
videos
yeah and then you make more of it than i
think that's really crazy that was sad i
felt
so bad jack and i were talking about
that afterwards i'm like shelby's
so long editing her video spends like 30
minutes just like
reacting to it yelling just after that i
was like i gotta find something to react
to like this is crazy
you still haven't posted my video yet i
know this has been
months i've been waiting for my response
to shelby church and it just never
happened
i made it before i had surgery and then
i just didn't like how it turned out i
was like i feel like
i rushed it like it wasn't really that
good okay
now it's been long enough i forget what
i said i totally forgot everything so
i'm like i should
do that again that's fair yeah how did
the surgery go can we talk about that
yeah i vlogged the whole thing so i'm
like
very open with that yeah um which is
nice because it pretty much paid for it
really oh my gosh surgery
they told me not to tell okay which is
wait the surgery people yeah was that
like a sponsorship type thing
not even can we can we can you say
something like that like i can't say
exactly how much
but yeah i can't say exactly how much
but i will say
it was not as much as a tesla okay okay
so that's like that's a deal
yeah i've noticed though i've done uh
like dental work and stuff in the past
and
every single time you're like are you
going through insurance are you going to
pay out of pocket humbly
how much is it out of pocket well if you
give us cash it'll be way less i'm like
i'm gonna do cash
seriously i think a lot of the insurance
is such a rip-off it is
and they explained it to me like if they
went through insurance they would have
to follow
all these different protocols like i
would have to have stayed
at a hospital one night rather than
this place called serenity in santa
monica which is like super nice and not
even
as much as a hospital and they would it
was just like different things they
couldn't do
i guess weird i don't get it i mean i
always thought that like you give them
cash and they're like okay we don't have
to report it but i think sometimes when
they go through the insurance companies
they have to start off billing so much
because they know the insurance
companies will try to negotiate that
down
and it's a fight like i heard like
hospitals have people like
their full-time job is just to negotiate
with insurance companies that seems like
disrupt honestly
it is this thing is really my mom was a
medical biller for a while
and it was like i mean i was like too
young to really
get it but now i'm like wait tell me
everything yeah
it's horrible when you really start
looking into it it's such a rip-off
yeah i was looking at health insurance
today cause i actually have to get that
now
i was like i don't even know what to get
cause i don't really go to the doctor
that's why i got jaw surgery this year
i don't know yeah i just did that so i
had to switch my insurance company from
california to las vegas so i had to get
like a brand new insurance i hated doing
that but i just picked the cheapest plan
because i know
it's like i i'm not gonna would i never
go to the doctor
and if i needed anything done like i
would just pay out of pocket for it like
we've been doing
i was thinking yeah we do like almost
weekly
illness tests and instead of going
through the insurance like i would
rather just pay out of pocket not deal
with it
it's so much easier so that's what i
just panicked i agree with that yeah
but then again there are certain
situations where it's like
50 000 bill or something like that so
yeah my deductible i think is like 8 500
so i will pay the first 8 500 or
whatever bill it is
per year everything over that is covered
just it's called a catastrophic plan so
like if anything is over that amount
it's covered
my loss is going to be 8 500 a year that
actually makes how much is your
insurance like monthly
uh i think like 280. i
i got i got so much money i didn't get
the lowest plan but i got
like the second to the lowest
yes yeah and there's some that are like
four or five hundred
for like a silver peanut oh yeah oh the
platinum plan
the platinum plan for me 30 is like 800
a month with dental insurance it's like
for what
like if i add it up because i think i
started doing the insurance at like 25
and there's a few years by the way i'll
admit to this now like i just didn't pay
for insurance
and i paid the penalty because i'm like
i'm not i'm not gonna get sick
uh i'd rather penalty it was one percent
i think of your net income yeah yeah
um what was it there was no penalty and
then there was like a one percent
penalty
i forget what year this was but that was
the year where i was like all right i'm
just gonna pay the penalty on that
and they check they're like yeah i think
i think there's something on a tax
return where you have to put in if you
had health insurance or not and
and yeah i just paid the penalty on that
i think it's like on your net
um but i thought like i just didn't want
it
yeah you know i figured well if anything
yeah that's what i was looking at so i
was like i really
if i go to the doctor i just go to
urgent care i don't have like a primary
care doctor
like yeah and even going through the
insurance i
hate it i i did one to uh like check for
like skin cancers and stuff like that
and i didn't know how much it would be
and it was like preventative
so it's covered but oh wow
like going and setting up an appointment
through the insurance companies you're
like
these people are in network and then i
had to wait for an appointment and then
i went to the appointment just so they
they could refer me to somebody else and
i'm like i knew exactly what i wanted to
just
check for skincare but no you got to go
to their person who then refers you to
somebody else
and then they coat they coded one thing
wrong they did like
they did like a blood sample or
something like that but they coded it
not as preventative and then i got a
bill for like 300 bucks for like blood
testing i'm like this is preventative
you have to fight it it was hours just
to fight this thing so they could code
it the right way so it was covered
wasn't worth it like i would have rather
just had not gotten
just not even gone not even gone you
know scarred me once i was actually
getting the jaw surgery they like gave
me a total an amount and i was like
okay but you guys sign this because like
i don't really trust it like
i don't know am i gonna get a bill
months later for like
thousands of dollars but i haven't good
yeah
but over it's a success so what was the
surgery
um it was double jaw surgery so my last
time i was on the podcast i was like
i don't think i had made the appointment
for it yet but i was like
knowing i had to do it but when i was
younger i had an underbite
kind of thing it was pretty mild they
were able to mostly get rid of it with
braces but then it kind of came back
over
time so yeah it like didn't even look
that intense or anything but
they just have to like break your jaw
reset it
i couldn't eat for like two months and
you were under
when that yeah obviously yeah no
she was awake how bad did it hurt
that's crazy really i was so
scared i was like dreading this for like
10 years like knowing i'm
eventually gonna have to do it but it
wasn't as bad as i thought because
i was like i thought it was going to be
even worse
i was mostly scared of the liquid diet i
was like i'm going to be hungry all the
time like how
but after the painkillers just made me
so tired i like didn't eat for a week
almost which is very
i couldn't imagine i would ever do that
but it was like
you're not hungry because your body's
recovering i guess those painkillers are
tough
how did you experience any sort of like
withdrawal
from those things i mean no okay i mean
they made me nervous so i tried to quit
after like two days because i was like i
don't want to get
addicted to this or something um but the
pain was
so bad then i was like okay i'm
back on it all the time but then after i
think a week and a half i was just
taking ibuprofen okay but like a lot of
ibuprofen all the time for like three
weeks
got it and then i was good how long was
the recovery
i mean i feel like i'm still recovering
like i still can't really feel my
numbness right yeah
yeah i still feel a little swollen like
not that swollen but like
i can feel it but it like looks mostly
normal
um and like i can't open my mouth as
wide as i could before like it's just
like doesn't feel the same like it's
really
tight you know none of that's permanent
right like you'd be able to open your
mouth more at some point like you'd be
able to feel at some point
yeah it should take like a year or two
to like right
my dad had that uh he had i think he had
too much of an
underbite so they did the same thing i
don't know if it was double jaw just
like the bottom jaw
but same sort of thing but he couldn't
um
feel for i think it was for a while but
there was a chance of
permanent nerve damage yep it's like i
might not fully get this back but
honestly it's like
i'm pretty used to it if i didn't get it
back it wouldn't be like
the end of the world but i really hope i
get it back
it's weird though how you just adjust
yeah it's such a subtle difference
though like you could
kind of notice it but not really yeah
uh it's it's very subtle can you chew
better
yeah way better before it took me
forever to chew and it was like just
tiring to eat
and now it's just faster and easier yeah
my jaw doesn't click all the way what
was it like with a liquid diet
and going from that to like eating again
were you nervous to eat
do you start with like jello or soup or
how is it it's like you're on a liquid
diet for a week
and then you're on soft foods for two
months
two months so what is this what what are
the soft foods consists of pepperoni and
cheese yeah
but even macaroni and cheese like you
can't actually chew it at all
so you still have to like mash it like
everything was just like mushy
i got really sick of it but what was the
first food that you ate that wasn't
mushy it was pizza
and i was so excited it was great were
you nervous at all that like
i feel like if i got jaw surgery i feel
like i would be so scared to like take a
bite or something like my jaw would just
like unhinge or yeah it just cracks
i was nervous and it kind of hurt
because i feel like the muscles and
whatever your teeth were like yeah
they're relaxed for a while maybe
so it felt weird it kind of hurt for a
few days but
i wasn't that nervous about actually
breaking my jaw because it's still like
screwed into place like there's like
plates and screws so there's no way it's
gonna like
do you like not eat soft food anymore um
she avoids all liquids i actually kind
of like soup more i never had soup
before but i'm like tomato basil soup
from the
right places can be really good huh yeah
have you tried beef jerky since then i
don't think that would go well
yeah i don't know do you not like beef
jerky or is it just
fine but like that would be a lot of
chewing okay do you still think what
about gum
i haven't chewed gum i think that'd be
fine but like
a carrot or even biting into that
chocolate i was like oh i kind of
need to like slowly do this yeah which
is weird how long do you have to be
careful for
i don't know until it feels normal i
guess
i can't really tell but it seems like
i've watched a bunch of youtube videos
of it
and after a year people seem
like way more past it can you eat apples
i wouldn't dare really yeah wow like i
saw some at the store and i was like oh
my god i don't think that would work
that's what we have we have an apple
right here here's the challenge
just to have a yeah
are you bummed at all about like the
eating stuff or does it
not matter in the bigger picture at this
point no because
it's like i'm glad i can eat whatever
before it was like when it was soft
foods in a liquid diet like it was you
know
horrible to i feel like i can eat
anything even though i have to just eat
it really slowly
but yeah i'm happy i got it over with
now though
yeah that's gotta be a relief too
because otherwise that would be on my
mind
the entire time just knowing one day you
got to do this yeah and it's hard to
find the time
where there's not something going on
like before there was always like
someone's wedding or like whatever it
was
then the illness yeah so i was like that
was
good timing from that perspective like
you can't really be around too many
people
anyway so you may as well right i had
been planning it for like a year
like i had to get my wisdom teeth out
and stuff and like find an orthodontist
but it just worked out like the timing
so that's fine very lucky
and you moved into a new place i saw
right yeah how was that
how much is that place and why did you
move that place is
i paid 500 a month not bad and before i
paid
like 2100 but before i had a room and an
office room
so now i don't have that but we have
like a big backyard
and just the house is way brighter it's
easier to record in any way so
i'll just record in the living room if i
want to and how many people live
four would you consider doing an
unlocked like elena did
what's that what we talked about it on
the episode you listened
unlocked yeah that was like a new cnbc
edition like
oh like having them go through all your
stuff no
it's it's like a house tour yeah
unlocked is where they go through
how much money is
you should do you should do a millennial
money yeah
i don't want them to go through
everything why why is it the expenses or
the income what are you
what are you hiding what are you afraid
of well i don't say how much i make on
like brand deals and stuff
i don't know but you could lump it
together yeah they don't they never
said like here's how much they got from
this sponsor they just lump it together
they
they call it like affiliates
sponsorships other
you could tell them how you want to
structure it but they'll put it in there
it's just
i feel like if i was going to do it i
would just want to make it myself
and like you should they do well same
they do well though
not the same when cnbc does it it's just
they put their
like special it's the spice yeah but
then you also have to like
they go through your records and stuff
like that seems annoying for sure
yeah you could just do one yourself i
think those do well
they're really interesting but it's not
the same great to react to
it is but it's not the same it's not it
is not well
i'm gonna react to it regardless but
some sometimes when cmbc does it they
they just put that extra little touch in
there
it's professional it's nice yeah i'm
like i don't want to do it but
i would do like a house tour at some
point
planning on doing that but i'm like not
in la as much so yeah house tours do so
well too you could do that
revealing my brand new dream home
yeah that would actually do well that's
what i would do get my roommates on
board
right but that's exciting i like the new
place it looks
really nice it looks really fancy too
it's fun yeah you would think we're
paying more
but the area is interesting is it is it
yeah we won't say exactly is it is it
towards the
the rougher part of that area yeah okay
yeah
but i mean nothing's like happened to us
it's just you know that citizen app yeah
i mean a lot of stuff goes down within
like point two miles of us
so i'm like um i don't know i'm not
gonna walk around with airpods in that's
for sure but that's anywhere i have the
citizen app too
and it's like always every like 15
minutes it's like
there's a robber yeah there's someone
pulled out uh
you know something dangerous there's an
altercation down the street like there's
always something
yeah the last place i lived though there
was nothing ever it was like
just families around so this
place is like i mean i'll like go
outside and i'll hear people like
fighting and that makes it sound even
worse than it is it's just like a lot of
people are around the area
yeah it's like a downtown of a city is
like that so
are you happy to be living there yeah i
actually think it's fun
like i love the yard in the house in
general it's super nice
my roommates are cool like i like it who
are you living with
um it's my friend morgan you've reacted
to her videos
oh yeah yeah twice yeah
so she lives there katie austin she's a
youtuber
fitness influencer and then we have one
more roommate who doesn't do youtube she
like works in
publicity okay yeah cool yeah
that's fun morgan we gotta have yeah she
wanna come on the podcast
i told her but she doesn't like going on
podcasts in general you know what i
reached out to her i think once but when
when the first video posted i think i
reached out to her right afterwards like
hey just a heads up the video is going
to be posting soon if you want to come
on let me know
no response yeah i think i think it's
just podcasting so
well no this is even before the podcast
i think this is like second channel
wow this is what i was doing the big
like confronting series you're like
you react to someone and then
immediately confront them those are the
things
because that sounds more intimidating
like confronting yeah i don't think i
said like i want to confront you
like then i'd understand like i'd
probably also be like what
i need you to come to my house so i can
confront you on camera
no yeah no but it was it's all been
pretty tame
if she wants to come on the invite she's
welcome she's always welcome
yeah i feel like a lot of youtubers now
it's like at least i kind of feel this
way i'm so used to editing my own stuff
that i'm like
oh to go on like a different
i mean this channel i trust but like i
don't know what i'd be getting myself
into on someone else's channel sometimes
or like
yeah a show a tv show i'm like i just
like editing my own stuff yeah i was
nervous with
uh jubilee the first time really nervous
i actually said
no to them on the first episode because
i didn't want them to like portray me
i've seen some of those um
uh what was it called middle ground
episodes yeah and the ones i've seen
the people are fighting back and forth
but i pick the ones with the most views
that have the most tension
and i didn't want to be like arguing
with anybody or like someone says
something to me and like
they throw that on there and i said no
and i was like
i'll only do it if i could watch the
episode beforehand and prove it
uh and they talk wow they agreed to that
no they didn't oh they didn't
they said and they but they called me
back and they say listen
our goal is to have you on multiple
times we don't want to like ruin a
relationship by like making you look
bad or like trying to spin it around in
a way
but they were honestly like if you say
something uh we have the right to use it
but just be careful what you say and
we're gonna we're gonna do our best to
make this a good episode and
to and they were really fair about it i
felt so i did it
uh but i was nervous about that i was
really nervous about millennial money
because i knew i
i felt like they were gonna just like
try to get this back i remember you said
that you were really scared because you
got like so much
like reaction commentary yeah were they
excited to make that one
after all the videos i don't know at the
beginning my first phone call with them
it seemed like they did not like my
reaction oh
really yeah because they're i forget
what they said they said something like
uh oh they they said are you so are you
planning to keep reacting to these
videos and i was like yeah i am like oh
well that's a i guess that's a very
youtube thing to do or like something
like that i was like
they weren't a fan of it i think they
felt i was worried they felt like i was
making a mockery like they were doing a
serious millennial money documenting
things and i'm like
just poking fun at it so i felt like
they were going to get me on
and then try to like turn the tables on
me uh i would be nervous
right and but they were really fair
and i think everybody in general no one
wants to make the other person look bad
yeah that's so awkward if you like film
a day and then you're
uploading this video and it's they're
not happy with it
just right don't feel good about that
right but i think most people in general
wouldn't want to ruin a relationship or
try to like
cut ties with somebody by like oh i'm
going to do this funny thing and
so it's all worked out true yeah
have you had any bad experiences with
with youtubers
not really i feel like i keep out of
most of the craziness do you not do many
collaborations
no not really not at all i don't i don't
i don't know i feel like they're they
don't have a huge benefit well i guess
i'll have people in my videos if i want
to interview them but it's not like a
traditional
like collaboration where like we're
making a video on their channel and my
channel
it's just like if i think they're gonna
add something to my video then i will
but
i don't really care if i'm on theirs it
really doesn't add that much of a
benefit yeah it used to a long time ago
i feel like it did
it'd be like go subscribe to them and
like you'd get a ton of subscribers i
don't know
i mean we've been like focusing a lot on
that kind of stuff
recently just collaborations stress the
problem with the main channel
because like everything that we've done
so far has done really well but that
would but that has not been
i'll do a video on you and then you do a
video on me it's we're documenting like
what you do you find these really unique
people or stories and then you like
you're just you document it
we've been doing that we've been oh we
have so excited the idubbbz
called finance cop okay yeah
so this will be yeah that's gonna be
huge the five i think five for five the
other four have each done a million
views and i'm hoping
his is going to be also a million views
at some point these they they all seem
to start off really slow and then after
like two weeks the algorithm just picks
it up and it does well
so i'm hoping this becomes the same i'm
on your channel yes
okay cool yeah so what i want to start
getting into once a month
is having some sort of guest on the
channel where i could just interview
them and have them talk about finances
cool so the bigger the better but yeah
it's it's interesting to get to uh
to hear about like how successful some
of these people are that just you have
no idea
until you really start talking to them
and how smart a lot of these people are
yeah it's fun interviewing people like i
just like doing that i'm glad youtube
like rewards those kind of videos now i
feel like five years ago it wouldn't
have done that well
but now it's like it's just easy they're
giving you kind of all the content
yeah get some cool b-roll it's fun do
you prefer interviewing people or being
interviewed
um i feel like i prefer interviewing
people
yeah i feel like i'm not as good as like
off-the-cuff answers
as if i like think about it more some
people are really good about that though
like that garyvee guy he's
yeah on it like all the time i know
wow you gotta grind you gotta grind work
hustle
don't give up started on that that's
jack you need to be working
i know i feel like everyone's kind of
over that yeah okay i had a moment
yeah isn't he only like
he's like so young and he says he like
grind it as hard as he can for 10 years
and now he's done now he can chill
i know he's not done that's what he said
no he says like i worked my a
off for like 10 years and now i can just
chill and it's like
i don't know what you're not crazy
that's what i don't like i don't know
it's crazy how he that was definitely
like a big blip of a trend
in like 2018 where he was like the it
but uh i always used to think it's so
crazy like how much he works and all the
hustle and this and that
but then the more i started getting into
the more i realized like i identify with
that
very much much kind of like wake up
early like work all day i mean yeah
when you were like let's record this
podcast at 7pm i was like
is that late you didn't have to say yes
to that
oh i feel bad yeah we were totally cool
like all day
oh really well i mean here's a roll i
guess
my preference was seven that was my
preference but like
you're the guest like we could work on
you if you're like seven
sevens late can we do three like i
totally would have done we're flexible
around you
that's like yeah well we have pr like
again this is just what i would suggest
but you're free to counter back and i
didn't realize that's great
oh i feel bad no i mean yeah well graham
asked me he was like should we do it at
like two or should we do it at like
seven and i was like let's go later yeah
we didn't know that it was like
i just like this time of year once the
sun's
gone i'm like i'm tired for no reason
like i don't know
okay well thanks for coming at seven
yeah i don't know i sometimes like those
late nights and early morning so there's
something magical about that like for me
the afternoon is usually like
harder to concentrate between twelve and
four
but early in the morning late at night
in the in
i like early mornings but late at night
i'm like i just want to chill
but this doesn't feel like work so
yeah it's fine same with us that's what
we go for yeah
i think every now and then though i'm
just i'm paranoid like does the audio
is the audio good like this is the stuff
i stress about all the time it's like
did we delete footage it's definitely
more work when it's your podcast
like it's like stressful with like all
these cameras like something in it
something bound to get messed up
yeah every single time yeah has anything
changed like
youtube wise since we had you on um
i don't know for your channel you know
actually i feel like my
rpm i kept calling it cpm back then
i feel like it actually has had gone up
in that last half of the year
but now january it's down a little bit
but like
beginning half of 2020 it was probably
like five dollars per thousand views for
your rpm
yeah and then by the end it was like 10.
for like the last six months
and my vlog channel which is so like
those aren't finance but it was like me
getting surgery but they were pretty
long like they'd be like 15 minutes
so three hours yeah that could be it
yeah ad rates did go up a lot
yeah because everything was like skip
ads there's like two ads
yeah they're going to keep going up too
i think so i'm sure of it year on year
the ad rates are going to keep going up
yeah people are really realizing that
youtube is the place to advertise and
they're throwing a lot of money in that
yeah
who's even going to watch tv anymore i
got honestly i don't i don't know what
to watch i'm like
yeah when we grow up yeah like watch tv
what do
see npr mentioned him no that's like a
good source of
unbiased news no way yeah i'm surprised
he hasn't gotten an offer from like a
huge network or anything get it yet
if if i were cnn or cnbc i would offer
kevin
like 10 or 20 million dollars and i'd
say just be exclusive with us for three
years and we'll pay you 10 million
a year they would be stupid not to give
him that offer yeah
10 mil a year and he just does that
i don't know if you would even take it i
don't think he would i don't think he
would either no but he's so good like
just off the cuff
just like saying anything yeah he has a
good like tv sounding voice
he does he was like made to do this like
the inflection yeah the voice inflection
is perfect for for news
so we're talking about kevin again i
know what are we doing right now
we got to see how it's like only about
meet kevin
i know that would be funny every guest
we have on we're just like so what do
you think of kevin
yeah yeah let's talk about kevin like
before you come on you have to watch
this video
oh my gosh watch the ads yeah is there
anybody out there who you
haven't met yet that you would really
want to meet like no i want to meet
kevin okay kevin is there anyone out
there who you like freak if you if you
saw this person
i don't think there are youtubers that i
would freak out
really i love john mayer he's not a
youtuber
it's amazing i'd be pretty excited if i
saw him yeah and like
met him but like in a casual way like in
a starbucks and
it's just i wouldn't ask for a photo oh
yeah like would you say like oh
in a starbucks yeah yeah yeah hopefully
you're not going there yeah
okay i like a cooler coffee shop yeah
yeah a cooler coffee shop yeah
like an alfred's or something oh my god
you would be there though if you if you
were anywhere it would be there
what about you graham who would you i
mean i already know dr phil
dr phil judge judge judy yeah um joe
rogan joe rogan
elon musk i mean i could yeah keenan
thompson yeah gail mitchell drake bell
josh peck yeah i feel like the drake
bell is a recent one anyway
someone like that for me would be would
be big one of these days i send them all
messages too
danny elfman was another one i've sent
him so many messages but i don't want to
be creepy about it
that's like our thing we send like 10
messages out to 10 different celebrities
and just see which one of them
like get back yeah they probably have
noticed now like i feel like they're
i'll see that kind of thing happen where
i'm like this person's
they're disappearing and then they're
coming back but it's like like the more
like
uh i don't even know gimmicky looking
finance
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
what questions you have for me because
you you came in and you're like i have a
few questions i want to ask you
i forget i did want to ask you about the
health insurance thing actually okay yes
i was doing that
today and i was okay so now i'm like
yeah oh this is maybe not fun for the
podcast
but if you refer people to like robin
hood or something like that do you just
they have like a max of 500 of referring
people yes you go past that somehow
i all the time i have thousands of
referrals that i did from robin hood
that i just don't get anything for
so it maxes out at 500 bucks uh they put
me on
i i had some sort of affiliate link
beyond that
i figured they must have but their terms
weren't exactly
what i had wanted uh so it never really
panned out
but um so you just don't get anything
for referring
for robin hood now yeah do you use it i
do okay oh yeah i use
every yeah i use every stock trading
platform out there
i like uh first trade charles schwab i
use everything out there
it's important that i know everything
out there yeah you're like an expert on
it yeah i feel like
you have a weeble i just got it did you
do your four free stocks um i got two so
far and then
they sent me the other two yeah so yeah
that one's definitely like this
interface isn't
so complicated it is i guess probably
good if you know how to use it there's
like more info
but i'm like okay what's going on yeah
rob sorry weeble is really good for
people who are like
deeply into stock trading because the
charts
are so much better than robin robin hood
is like you're just like
tipping your dipping your feet in there
just you know dipping your feet
your toes your toes so easy it's very
easy
so that's why what i like about robin
hood it's just you swipe up
weeble's a little bit more complicated
but it's more thorough
yeah i just recorded a video where i
invested a thousand dollars just picking
individual stocks that i think that i'm
like i just feel like it might
might not if you want to react to
something yeah did you see my stock
picking monkey video
i didn't watch that yet oh watch that
yeah it probably isn't going to do
well oh it's doing well isn't it my stop
taking monkey video yeah
no no no no it did the monkey monkey
picked well
really well okay so we're going to react
to shelby's
portfolio right now so i did
a video that'll it'll probably be up by
the time this is up
that was like i mean most of the money i
invest is not in robin hood it's like
some that financial advisor i was
telling you about that last time
but it's like fun to play around on here
and so
it ended up doing pretty well and i just
picked some random ones
so here you can react all right let me
see can we screen record that
yeah okay all right so here we go okay
so seven thousand dollars
uh but most of these are only got like a
hundred so you got like fractional
shares so yeah what is pll
i've never is that one of your free
stocks no i actually picked this one
and they they're like lithium for
electric car batteries
this is fantastic you bought in 45 it's
worth 61
now yeah i probably like three days ago
airbnb
is great i bought some airbnb a while
ago it's doing decent
alibaba depends what price you bought
this
at 259 tuesday yeah you know they had
that
recent controversy where the uh jack ma
some disappeared for a little while
that's this big dip that you see right
here
260's yeah so you did you did well on
that facebook is great i think facebook
is is so undervalued i really do right
because people think like facebook who
uses it but they forget
instagram yes 100 and facebook
they're ramping up their marketing and
video right now so i think
facebook uh to i could see this being a
350 stock
i think facebook is great to hear it
yeah uh and facebook is one of the few
companies too where if i were just to
hold something for like five years i
think facebook and google would be
would be how about apple um i bought a
little apple
but i i don't know i keep feeling like
they they're they're trading beyond what
they should be
no but they're going to keep going up
but they will have years
i feel like everyone just always keeps
buying the products that's true
so i don't see myself ever not buying
whoever switches from apple to not apple
no like nobody i'm invested in apple
it's just i'm not buying
more apple like i am facebook or google
okay yeah
then we have starbucks uh
103 102. starbucks is the only one so
far you've lost money on
that sign well it's been like three days
so okay i feel like this one
will eventually and i just spent money
at it so i was like
i think starbucks will be okay uh let's
see
49 48 warren buffett
i think his uh his holding is in
coca-cola i'm not a huge fan of it just
because i feel like just
i don't know too much about their
business it's just sugary drink like i
don't drink
coca-cola so i wouldn't invest in them
but they own
other drinks i was thinking and they're
they're still
down from a year ago
and i feel like it's not going anywhere
like it's not coke isn't going to go
away
yeah what are the other beverages they
own um they own a bubbly i think honey
[Music]
that's super popular now chico yeah
do they oh back to kevin that's going to
be big yeah okay
yeah tobacco that that's the new uh
lacroix
yeah it's like so trendy all of a sudden
yeah mcdonald's is fantastic
i love mcdonald's i bought their stock
too
i think this is a a solid hold and you
get a 2.3
dividend mcdonald's fantastic
uh apple good i like that look at that
your average cost 117.
great buy have you been adding to this
portfolio
well now i have yeah i was just 396.
i know i'd say the biggest thing for me
is that you should have put a lot more
money in here
let's see let's see your game stop ready
uh 209 this is going to come out like
three weeks from now this podcast
episode it's gonna be interesting to see
like
what's up with gamestop because right
now it's gonna be no idea yeah so
my prediction it's it's a hund i don't
wanna say 100 i'm almost positive
this is gonna completely collapse i
agree i think it's gonna go down
i think she should just put in 20 bucks
as a market order when the market opens
i wanted to do something where if it
goes up to like
270 it automatically sells oh sure sure
sure
i i i bought into i guess i could say
this i bought into games
just this was a gamble back at like 17
18
because i saw it a month ago on wall
street bets and i was just like you know
what
i have some fun i don't want to like
make it seem like i'm just
taking risky risky investments but i had
a little like extra
fun money threw some fun money in there
it's up like over 700 percent
yeah and then i'm crazy and now i'm i'm
like
i keep in my head just like i go to my
calculator on my phone i'm like
if i invested fifty thousand dollars i
would have had this
and then i just keep thinking well had i
done a hundred thousand dollars
and it's hard not to look at that and be
like if i just invested 200 grand i
could have made over a million dollars
so but you know so be it i thought about
that with tesla i invested in that in
2019
and then i sold it like i got it at 200
and i sold it at 700 and i was like
that's like if i could go back in time
and do one thing
you put more money into that yeah but
also like whatever it still like doubled
or tripled my money yeah tripled
can't complain yeah no you can never
complain about taking profits and i
really think gamestop and this is so
interesting because
this is gonna be three weeks from now
yeah uh this is one this is the only
stock that i bought that i had the
intention of
of selling it short term every other
stock that i buy
i'm buying with the intention of just
holding it forever what are you going to
sell
um my answer right now is by friday
friday whatever the so am i most likely
that's most most likely and i feel like
i'm at this weird point right now where
i shouldn't be getting
greedy but this is meant from the very
beginning just to be like a
that's a fun let's let this ride there's
no way i'm losing money on this thing
so no matter what i'm in the green and
you can get a couple videos out of it
probably
uh i'm i'm making one video uh because i
don't want to ever be seen as like
trying to pump up a stock the video that
i made
is so if anything it's negative towards
gamestop like it works against me
in this video i'm making because i'm
explaining like it's not sustainable
it's gonna crash 90 of people buying it
are going to lose money
but this could go to a thousand or it
could go to 500 but
90 people will lose yeah but i never
want to make like another how much we
made from game so cuz in
it promotes risky behavior and it goes
against my message
but i think this this would be like the
average person being like hey
i have you know 100 bucks let me just go
and gamble it away like
50 bucks that's the equivalent basically
so yeah
but yeah when i was making this video
picking these stocks i i felt like i had
to say like five times i was like this
is not all my money
like i swear yeah not putting it all
into these random
my my biggest fear is that people copy
what i do like
stock by stock and that's why i've never
shared my entire portfolio because i'm
so afraid i share it and
there's there's going to be someone out
there who buys definitely exactly like
every stock in proportion and if it goes
down
i don't want to be like well why'd you
copy me then you know i bought these way
way back then don't be upset at me so
yeah i don't want to show that so that's
one of the few things
that yeah just in case figure it out
but i could say after the fact and this
is posting after
i would have sold so yeah we'll see
we'll see yeah it'll be interesting yeah
cool is there anything else i feel like
it'd be fun to make some predictions
since this is the first time we're ever
doing a podcast episode
three weeks prior yeah that i'm
okay i'm trying to think of some stuff
do you think that it's gonna happen with
amc and blackberry what's happening with
gamestop yes okay
blackberry 5050. okay is this before the
hype of it though
this is like the beginning beginning of
pipe yeah okay so they might pump those
stocks up i'm gonna check that out
we'll see yeah wall street bets doesn't
want to split their attention right now
between them
they want to focus all of their
attention right now in gamestop do you
think there's going to be any sec
regulation on
activity like this in the future no
so what's basically happening is these
random people
it's okay together yeah like let's buy
this
basically yeah so what no it started off
with this one guy he did
research and found that like listen
gamestop
90 of people out there are shorting the
stock but they're shorting more stocks
than
are available on the market so he made a
prediction
and said under these certain
circumstances as soon as there's any
good news there's going to be what's
called a short squeeze
which means the price of the stock is
going to go up based on good news
that's going to cause people to cover
their short positions by buying the
stock and closing out
because they buy the stock and close out
that means the price of the stock is
going to go up because there aren't as
many stocks available that they could
pick from
right so that's going to keep causing
stock to increase
exponentially uh until all of the shorts
are covered
and because there's so many uh shorts
out there
uh this stock price could go up like the
hundreds of dollars
just because of that who are these
people getting together to short it
wall street bets it's a community of two
million uh
traders who read this form
all the time including myself and when
they see what's called
due diligence on something like that
that gets upvoted they're like wait a
second this guy might be right
combine that with a lot of really big
news for gamestop they had
uh this this guy who went in he's the
guy of chewy.com
go in and try to turn the company around
they did a deal with microsoft and sony
to sell their games and their discs so
they have all this good news that's now
driving up the price of the stock so
that was a catalyst
combined with wall street bets combined
with all the shorts
that make this the perfect storm and
like this rare opportunity where like
everything lined up and then when wall
street vets got a hold of that they said
guys
if we all just work together we all buy
these 60
call options on gamestop when we drive
the price of the stock up if we all just
do this
the price of the stock will go up and
sure enough when you get a community
that's like you know what
i'm in let's do it you've got so many
people buying up all the stocks
and sending this price higher and
then you have people saying we need to
come together and just agree
we're not going to sell the stock until
it hits a thousand
then we'll actually get our price if we
all just stick with the plan
we'll get a thousand but then people are
gonna sell it at 9.99 because they don't
want to be that and then there's gonna
be someone thinking
so that's in my video that's what i said
if if people expect a thousand it'll be
9.90 but then i would be like people are
thinking 990 so i'll be 980.
and other people are going to be like
well she's 90 i'm 970. yeah and they're
gonna
there's definitely like a social
experiment youtube type video on this
right
how high do you think it's going to go
i don't know so there are people out
there just losing a ton off this
short sellers yeah now those are
institutional investors with
billions of dollars okay so no one's
like too worried about them
um individual traders could buy in at
the peak and lose
the short sellers are the institutional
investors who have billions of dollars
of capital behind them so right now it's
really between uh
wall street bets and big institutions
wall street bets wants the big
institutions to bleed money
and just lose as much money as possible
that they could get in return
that's really what this is about how
high could it go i would be
shocked if it hits a thousand but
volkswagen which is the example that
they used that happened back in like
2009 i believe
went from being like a 50 stock to a 900
stock for a few minutes before it
crashed down
a few minutes is how long it was sitting
there for that's it
so this could be a little blip on a rate
this literally could be
go from 400 to 800 in a matter of like
an
hour maybe 900 for like 30 seconds or
something before it
like once it once it hits a peak and
starts selling off everybody is going to
start selling off
so it's you got to be on it like so fast
and you can set an automatic
yeah selling you could you could
so uh i'm gonna say 565
that's my price peak i was i was
telling myself i'd sell it like eight so
you think eight yeah
what about you shelby just put a number
out there we'll see who wins okay
um 700. 700. oh if we're talking
realistic
realistically
i have a feeling probably close to four
i don't think we'll hit four
realistically i think it'll be like a
390 or so
yeah the problem is that i won't want to
sell then
yeah and and i i look back at this i'll
be like ram you should have sold
should have sold then you could sell
some of it yeah the problem is it's so
volatile
that this is a stock that on i think it
was
monday or friday it went up 100
and then trading halted crashed back
down
below where it was trading at the the
day prior before going back up again
so you don't really know where it's
gonna go like this could drop
fifty percent and then go but then but
that's not it then it'll triple in price
the next day you don't know oh my gosh
yeah yeah this is for real gambling yeah
so look at that 20 bucks
yeah if you double your money on that
sell it immediately
and at least you'll make 20 bucks yeah
yeah i'll make 40.
those from the bet yeah oh yeah shelby
what do you think about
rollerblading oh yes as a first
date idea hmm or
roller skating okay let's say oh i went
like ice skating but i was like a second
date once
no yeah that's normal isn't it as a
first date it might be a little
too much going on like what if you fall
i don't know uh ladies
jack has been receiving a few messages
lately in the dms
and jack has been responding to you
and we have two potential candidates
who slid in the dms to go rollerblading
it's not potential anymore
not maybe not knowing them maybe not so
anyway we had such a fun time we were
driving back
from las vegas to l.a we could film this
podcast
and the entire car ride back we were
figuring out what to say back to these
messages and we came up with the
perfectly crafted messages
back and forth they were going so well
and then i'm like jack just get the
number get the number
jack got the number and then she sent a
text and then we're going back and forth
over text we're trying to figure out
like how do we
coordinate this and then as soon as jack
says
uh well you talked about rollerblading
no
you we what was it you why don't you
read it
you suggested rollerblading and they
were like uh
i'm good wait why is that weird i don't
understand why that's weird okay we want
your opinion on these text messages and
if you think they're okay
okay i mean so far this is looking
pretty good
all right all right but then it takes a
turn and rollerblading is considered
cool here
oh this is where it takes the turn
skates are cooler
wow okay she's like actually really
serious about this
that's what i thought i thought she was
dead serious like i don't think so
i was serious too no but graham's like
oh she's like just joking around messing
around
see and then you're slightly offended
okay first off you're totally wrong
they haven't been cool true i think if
roller skates is like a roller rink and
you're like don't know how to use the
roller blades so you get
right it's like the beginner stuff yeah
we should put this to the test what's
your schedule like this week
oh and then so she was just like bored
and then it was like oh wait you want to
actually meet up like
that i think is that here's the thing
okay why don't you let me show you
just a number let me explain this a
little bit better okay
so i said like what's your schedule like
this week graham told me to say that
i didn't want to say that i think that's
too aggressive i don't think so at all
that's
passive what's your schedule like yeah
because then it's like how long is this
going to go on
of just texting you might as well meet
but then she says i'm slightly offended
i'm like okay graeme she's
backing away and then and then graham
said you gotta go in for the
for the final blow and i was like and
then he said
send this it's not my fault that you
like roller skates he told me to send
that
okay and then he said you're only
offended because you'd know i'd win
i didn't want to say that i went into
like funny i wanted to like
now it seems like whoa are you actually
like
mad about this wait i know i thought i
sounded too genuinely
like upset like yeah i know i would
think so i'd be like what the heck
wait wait so i guess some of it doesn't
translate well over text
yeah like that's what i was saying if
you're like oh i'm offended be like oh
you're only offended because you know
i'd win i
i guess the tone maybe doesn't translate
like smiley face let's go and like
the smirking one yeah should i send it
no no okay so
so what we were saying what we were
saying is jack like send her a link to
this episode be like
we were saying that jack should call her
right now should i call her
yeah and just because at this point i
don't care
like i think it'll be i know it
nothing's gonna happen
so i figure like at least we can get
some information from this and maybe see
where
where we went wrong yes and learn for
the future
yeah i feel like she's not gonna answer
but hopefully
i would say she is going to answer do
you want to do you want to bet
okay i think i have like 20 bucks on me
i'll get 20 dollars
wait so you think she's not gonna answer
right i think she's not gonna i think
she's gonna answer
all right so 20 i have 20 bucks
something that would be funny
okay oh my god all right so i have 20
bucks this is terrible
whatever it is i'll give it to you right
now i think there is nothing
that can go wrong okay you have to
manifest that okay
that's what i'm nervous about hey you're
you're live on the podcast don't say
live
oh just like hey we're filming a podcast
right now can i ask you a really quick
question
okay i don't want to lose twenty dollars
it's okay you'll make it back uh i know
but
she's not going to answer but she could
go back it's game over wait
wait what's your voicemail
what if it's like hey it's ricardo you
should leave a voicemail
the voicemail
please leave your message leave
voicemail
to replay your map you could delete this
oh you can do yes
press two to delete and re-record your
your message has been deleted hang up
please
record your message at the tone okay
hey this is jack uh we're recording a
podcast right now
uh and we just wanted to get some
information
uh regarding the uh the exchange that we
had yesterday all right thank you so
much
let me know they hang up
hey that was good i probably i would
have started laughing like sooner or
later
oh
she'll be like okay all right i'm gonna
give this to you if she calls back you
give it back okay there you go
what we have learned from this is that
you win some and you lose
okay that's our key i was nervous for
you
i was so nervous for you so it felt like
it was like a prank call
all of a sudden yeah like oh god that
was so terrible voicemail
dude okay i'll leave this on um not on
do not disturb so she does call back
okay then we'll all know then i feel
like she's gonna listen to the message
and purposely not call back after that
dude i think the message actually hurt
my channel
that was so bad that couldn't have gone
anywhere she thinks it's gonna be a
pretty
i couldn't have gone worse so do you
have any other advice for
for jack um
i don't know i mean it's probably tough
during quarantine
yeah pretty much maybe she has the
illness maybe that's it that could be it
yeah yeah
or a good excuse or a good excuse
maybe she's just so nervous i don't know
maybe maybe she doesn't
intend on meeting up with anyone she's
just like
was also on a road trip that could be a
thing too it's just boredom yeah it's
just sometimes it's just
bored just go and you know deck someone
back and forth and then just let it be
maybe she thinks she doesn't deserve me
probably that's probably it that's
probably
yeah now that i think about that's
definitely a reason
that's our takeaway that that's it we'll
go with that i think we're good
yeah yeah anything else cool well guys
yeah thank you so much for watching i
really appreciate it and shelby thank
you so much for coming on
again having me again we'll have you on
like every six months you could be like
that recurring guest
who's just we just chat we just chit
chat every six months or so this has
been fun
make sure to subscribe if we're not at
100k yet um
you better subscribe add us on instagram
get your four free stocks down below in
the description this is not investment
advice for entertainment purposes only
thanks again for watching and until next
time
yeah so we randomly generated like a
list of like 30 stocks
and then the monkey randomly picked 10
stocks out of those randomly generated
30 stocks
oh what she's calling holy [ __ ]
she's calling i want my money back okay
is that on
is that on yes yes okay
hello oh my goodness i missed your call
what's up
hey not a lot how about you uh not too
much
okay full transparency uh i was with my
friend
in a car my friend and his girlfriend in
a car and we were crafting
perfect messages to send to you
yesterday
shut up i swear and
is that why you were so witty are you
not actually oh my god we were witty
i was i'll take credit for 99 of the wit
my friend can get the
the one percent oh yeah okay the
rollerblades this is actually
probably the most important question
well she can would you
would you have showed up with roller
roller skates
possibly i told you i told you she was
going to show up with roller skates
wait hold on i got it you just speak up
it's okay it's
oh oh um one second
okay last question
are you ready what's your schedule like
oh what's your schedule like all right
thursday 4 p.m
okay all right all right i'll see you
then boom
look at me wow mr date to my
these are like my random i'm gonna give
you this back
put it towards gamestop oh okay so there
you go thanks will
i gift my gift for you gamestop all
right
this is a 30-something episode and this
podcast has made okay just say the 38th
and then if you post it earlier we'll
have the 37 then yeah it doesn't matter
38th ever
episode the 38th okay i say that yeah
yeah yeah 30th ever episode of the iced
coffee hour monday 35
550. okay okay